peu confirme dans les meilleurs délais
merci la parole et à monsieur gérard
manuel merci monsieur le président mes
chers collègues
monsieur le premier ministre vous ne
pouvez pas l'ignorer l'agriculture est
en crise ce n'est pas d'actualité
métérologiques de l'année dont vous
n'êtes pour rien qui peut nettoyer un
ciel bien sombre
la france agricole plombé par ses
charges à succès par une sur
transposition des réglementations
européennes perd au fil des années sa
superbe de sa compétitivité
il ya quelques années encore la révolte
française était la deuxième au monde
la première en europe en particulier
pour sa capacité exportatrice cette
année aller au 3ème rang européen et ce
n'est pas fini
à regarder ce que vous apprêtez à faire
je veux parler de la révision du cadre
national pour l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires
monsieur le premier ni ce je vais vous
interroger aujourd'hui
concernant le fond du nouvel arrêté que
vous mettez un résultat sion avec quatre
de vos ministres
les nouvelles modalités des zones non
traitées dit znt que ce soit en
arboriculture en multi culture ou en
clôture basse n'ont pas d'équivalent en
europe et auront des conséquences
économiques et sociales graves de plus
admettez que c'est d'une complexité son
nom dans les fêtes
vous supprimez du jour au lendemain 10 %
de la surface cultivée en france
dans mon département celui de l'aube ce
sont trente quatre mille hectares qui
seront ainsi impacter la question
l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires en agriculture est
certes complexe la protection de
l'environnement et de la santé doit être
le fil conducteur d'une politique
publique mais dans votre approche
concernant l'utilisation des produits
phyto allez vous enfin porter un regard
scientifique pragmatique et non pas
arbitraire et sans aucune étude d'impact
je vous remercie
merci la parole et à monsieur stéphane
le foll mini jungles et que le dire de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt sur le
président monsieur le député vous avez
posé la question premier ministre s'est
mise agriculture qui va vous répondre
la première chose que je voulais vous
dire d'abord sur les baisses de charges
que vous évoquez je voudrais rappeler
que grâce aux décisions qui avaient été
prises l'an dernier c'est à milliards
600 millions de baisses de charges dont
400 millions imputés au budget de
l'agriculture qui seront aujourd'hui
comptabilisé pour l'agriculture ce qui
n'a jamais été fait auparavant
le deuxième point vous dit que nous
serions les champions de la sueur
transposition européenne
je vais vous rappeler que quand je suis
arrivé j'ai eu droit à un contentieux
européen inquiété avant que j'arrive sur
la directive nitrates que ce contentieux
aujourd'hui est réglée grâce au plan
d'action est ce que nous avons fait en
concertation avec la profession agricole
etc
aujourd'hui dans le même temps où la
france est sortie de ce contentieux je
vous invite à regarder ce qui va se
passer en allemagne où l'allemagne elle
est en contentieux et pour toute la
surface agricole du pays
donc chacun doit bien prendre la mesure
de la situation
ensuite vous évoquez s'est arrêté sur
les phytosanitaires
je rappellerai que c'est une association
professionnelle qui a retoqué
l'arrêté en demandant plus de souplesse
et qui a fait que conseil d'état
quelquefois contesté par certains a
demandé à ce que nous fassions cet
arrêté c'est arrêter intégrera ce qui
existe déjà en particulier sur
l'utilisation des phytosanitaires avec
des vitesses de vent qui sont déjà
actuellement en cours ce qui concerne
aussi la protection de l'eau et se s'est
arrêté sera négociée est en tout cas le
préfet biche qui a une mission sur la
simplification rendre à ce rapport le 18
octobre et nous avons parfaitement
conscience de la nécessité à la fois de
protéger et j'aimerais bien que le
rappel du crâne les populations qui sont
confrontées quelquefois aux
phytosanitaires et en même temps de
permettre aux agriculteurs de pouvoir
prêter dans de bonnes conditions de
protection
c'est ça l'enjeu de cet arrêté le 18
octobre préfet biche rendre à son son
avis et surtout ne laissez pas dire
comme ça a été dit tout à l'heure mais
les pourcentages de sueur